un amas de tôle grise c'était le plus
grand centre commercial de la ville dans
les décombres ces tee shirts et chemises
sur leurs cintres comme suspendu dans le
désastre
on distingue les caisses du supermarché
et sur le parking les caddies quasi
intacte après nice
daria tenez la bijouterie elle tremble
encore ce matin elle a échappé de peu
aux deux missiles russes qui ont frappé
après avoir la totale il ya eu la sirène
l'alerté rien alors on s'est mis à
courir vers la sortie arrière et puis
trois minutes plus tard il ya une
explosion en avait du verre partie dans
les cheveux sur nos vêtements mais aussi
de la fumée les gens couraient c'était
effrayant
combien de clients ont-ils pu s'échapper
il y avait selon kiev jusqu'à un millier
de personnes dans le centre ce matin
voici les restes du missile exposée pour
la presse il faisait 11 mètres de long
et plus de 5 tonnes toute la nuit les
sauveteurs ont travaillé pour dégager
les débris et retrouver des corps c'est
de la barbarie
ce sont des meurtriers
je n'ai pas de mots
le centre commercial était-il visée ou
est ce une erreur de tir il est adossé à
une immense usine ici en bleu sur la
carte une usine qui a servi à l'effort
de guerre en 2014 des munitions étaient
tels stocker hier réponse du ministre de
l'intérieur ukrainien
y'avait rien militaire dans une zone non
les sirènes viennent de retentir les
secouristes qui étaient sur chantiers
sont donc sortis alors selon moscou
aignan ce n'est pas ce centre commercial
qui était visé mais en stock de
munitions à proximité
les magasins auraient simplement pris
feu mais moscou affirme aussi et là nous
pouvons le contredire que le centre
commercial ne fonctionnait pas au moment
de l'explosion